imagine you're getting ready to log off
for the day and you've just had an
urgent request an analyst at your
company can access the data they need
and will because you're the admin of the
cloud deployment they need your help
figuring out why they can't access the
data they need
your heart sinks a little because
debugging access issues can be so time
consuming but do they have to be let's
look at how a policy troubleshooter can
help you fix these type of issues fast
policy troubleshooter empowers admins
too easily and quickly understand why
specific actions are allowed or Not by
the IIM policies these actions could be
accessing resources like a storage
bucket or calling specific apis
in order to use policy troubleshooter
you need to provide just three pieces of
information the email address of a
specific user or service account the
resource in question and the permission
you can find this information in both
logs and in permission to night error
messages provided directly when users
experience access issues policy
troubleshooter takes this information
and examines the IAM policies that apply
to the resource to reveal whether any of
the user's existing rules include the
required permissions
if the user doesn't have adequate access
the troubleshooter lists the roles in
your IAM policy that contain the
permission in case you want to Grant the
user one of those roles
policy troubleshooter speeds up
debugging even in complex use cases such
as troubleshooting access to a resource
granted by a group or a nested groups or
understanding how policies are inherited
across the resource hierarchy
so going back to the original example an
administrator is troubleshooting a cloud
storage bucket access issue for a data
analyst let's resolve it using policy
troubleshooter first you'll head into
the policy troubleshooter tool
then provide the user or service account
email a resource and a permission
the full resource name reference
documentation is linked in the video
description
note that you can also add multiple
resource permission pairs to check at
one time
now click check access
the results page contains several pieces
of information evaluation details show
the summary of the principle resource
and permissions you are troubleshooting
the IIM allow policy section immediately
indicates whether the user has
permission to the resource
the resources section is a list of the
specified resource and its ancestors in
this case the project that owns the
bucket
however note that if you don't have
permission to view and ancestors allow
policies the resource list will not
include that ancestor
after selecting the project resource the
role bindings section populates A list
of rule Bindings that are currently
present in the project
by default this list only shows what are
called relevant bindings
relevant role bindings are role Bindings
that include a roll with that specified
permission or include a custom role that
can be edited to add the specified
permission
the access column indicates whether the
role has been granted to the user
if a role binding includes a condition
the access column will show as
conditional and The Binding details will
display the full condition
in this case the storage object viewer
binding is conditional on the day of the
week and the user's access is limited to
Mondays according to the central time
zone
in this demo we showed policy
troubleshooter using the Google Cloud
console but it's also available using
the Google Cloud CLI or the rest API for
simple queries like the one we showed
using the Google Cloud console is
typically fastest for more complex
scenarios consider the gcloud CLI or the
rest API we hope that policy
troubleshooter will help reduce the time
and the headache for anyone debugging
access issues in the cloud to learn more
about policy troubleshooter and the
other solutions that are part of the
policy intelligence portfolio check out
cloud.google.com policy intelligence